mais d'abord notre premier débat autour
des relations difficiles entre emmanuel
macron et les élus des territoires jeudi
le président de la république viendra
ici au congrès un rendez-vous nous
souvenez vous en qu'il avait snobé en
2018 symbole d'une première moitié de
mandat marqué par certaines
incompréhensions et des polémiques samia
de chiens
tout a très mal commencé entre
à peine élu emmanuel macron supprime la
taxe d'habitation
l'une des principales ressources des
communes les élus sont en colère et vont
le faire savoir bruyamment au président
lors de sa première visite au congrès
des maires de france la taxe
d'habitation sera supprimé en trois
tranches pour 80% de la population
française
alors pour cela
vous pouvez être en désaccord j'ai
toujours vous savez c'est toujours
demander aux gens d'aimer mythique de ne
pas siffler c'était des militants je
peux demander la même chose au maire
pendant un an le fossé ne va cesser de
se creuser entre emmanuel macron et les
élus locaux en 2018 il ne vient pas au
congrès des maires la rupture semble
consommée nous avons eu bien entendu de
très mauvaises surprises la suppression
des emplois aidés la remise en cause de
la politique du logement social la
volonté de faire que le maximum soit
prélevée sur les différents fonds qui
sert sur nos territoires
c'est le mensonge permanent
c'est finalement la crise des gilet
jaune qui va permettre de renouer le fil
emmanuel macron lance son grand débat
national qu'il entame symboliquement par
une tournée des maires de france les
maires sont remis au coeur du débat
parce que jusqu'à maintenant on avait
plutôt l'impression d'être malmenés
donc en tant qu'élu donc ça c'est quand
même quelque chose que pour nous c'est
important l'aîné 2019 et celle de la
réconciliation
cette fois quand emmanuel macron revient
au congrès des maires le ton a changé
tant appris de votre sens du dialogue de
l'unité de la proximité
tant appris oui j'ose le dire de vous
mais l'année suivante la pandémie de
covin 19 va de nouveau tendre les
relations entre l'exécutif et les élus
locaux en première ligne les maires
dénoncent une gestion trop centralisée
de la crise sanitaire la bataille du
dernier kilomètre le l'acheminement des
masques les protections cadre général et
la caricature de l'impuissance que nous
dénonçons de l'état dans les territoires
sur beaucoup de secteurs et sur celui ci
en particulier le coït 19 pèse sur les
finances des communes 5 à 6 milliards
d'euros estime l'association des maires
de france qui demande à l'état de régler
la facture pour sa dernière visite au
congrès des maires emmanuel macron est
de nouveau attendu de pied ferme cette
année
les enjeux de la réconciliation entre le
chef de l'état et les maires de france
et le thème de notre premier débat ici
depuis le le palais des congrès à paris
vous entendez autour de moi il ya de
l'ambiance il ya des élus il ya beaucoup
de monde ici porte de versailles et on
va débattre autour de cette thématique
on est vraiment au coeur de l'actualité
puisqu'il ya un nouveau président de
l'association des maires de france qui
va être désigné d'ici demain on a
commencé à voter ici dans les dans les
couloirs je vous propose de découvrir
mes invités tout de suite franck
louvrier le maire de la baule bonsoy
franck louvrier bienvenu merci d'être là
vice-président a l'air de la région des
pays de la loire karl olive bonsoir karl
olive maire dvd de poissy dans les
yvelines évidemment proche des manuels
macron vous avez déjà annoncé que vous
le soutenez avant même qu'il soit
officiellement candidat à la
présidentielle pascal perrineau
politologue bonsoir et bienvenue à vous
de vous retrouver dans un autre décor
que notre décor habituel de public sénat
vous êtes ancien directeur du centre de
recherches politiques de sciences po et
lætitia cru pas éditorialiste politique
bonsoir laetitia heureux de vous
accueillir évidemment ici aussi
peut-être avant de rentrer dans le vif
de ce débat d'évaluer l'état des
relations entre le prénom république et
lmr un mot de l'image de ces derniers
pascal perrineau on dit souvent que ce
sont les élus préférés des français
c'est toujours vrai ça ça ne se dément
pas c'est toujours vrai à sciences po
nous avons un baromètre de confiance
politique qui hélas au fur à mesure des
années est devenu un baromètre de
défiance politique mais une population
échappe régulièrement à cette défiance
majoritaire qui est parfois une défiance
d'ailleurs qui tourne au rejet et la
population qui échappe ce sont les
maires les maires ont régulièrement une
cote d'amour qui tourne autour de 60 70
% des personnes interrogées dans le
contexte actuel de crise de la politique
de rejet des élus c'est une performance
et cela est valable dans toutes les
tranches d'âge dans tous les milieux
sociaux dans toutes les sensibilités
politiques sauf un peu vers les extrêmes
que ce soit la gauche de la gauche ou la
droite de la droite peut-être parce que
ce sont des familles politiques qui ont
moins d'élus
1 les pieds dans la glaise c'est aussi
fort qu'un sentiment d'appartenance
nationale c'est à dire qu'on se sent
français mais aussi on se sent de sa
ville de son village c'est très
important cette affaire parce que vous
savez on dit très souvent les français à
juste titre ont une fibre nationale
cette nation qui a été construite par
l'état l'état monarchique et ensuite
l'état républicain c'est vrai que les
français qu'il soit de gauche de droite
ou d'ailleurs porte cette identité
nationale forte mais en même temps nous
avons tous une seconde patrie j'ai
l'habitude de dire qu'il ya une grande
patrie c'est la nation et ya une petite
patrie c'est la commune est ce que vous
le ressentez l'un et l'autre avant de
parler d' emmanuel macron je voudrais un
peu votre retour d'expérience d'élus de
mère de deux jeunes merde si vous êtes
maire depuis juillet 2020 franck
louvrier j'apporterai un petit bémol à
ce que dit pascal perrineau parce que
bien sûr que c'est sans doute encore
l'élu le plus apprécié dans notre
république mais on voit que les taux de
participation sur les élections
municipales
mais ce à chaque à chaque élection est
donc de ce fait là y'a quand même là
aussi une distance qui se crée entre le
maire et la population et il faut
regarder ça comme le lait sur le feu je
pense que ce qu'on vous vcu ce qu'on
vous voit et ce qu'on peut vivre avec
d'autres élus et d'autres élections
notamment élections aussi présidentielle
on a aussi ce résultat là maintenant fur
et à mesure du temps avec l'élection du
maire ou les participations sont plus
faibles qu'auparavant donc je dirais que
bien sûr qu'ils aient un lien
particulier il ya un lien du quotidien
il ya un lien qui fait qu'en fin de
compte on est parfois la bonne à tout
faire de la république on mais on est
aussi ce que ceux qui sont au quotidien
au plus proche des préoccupations des
français donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce lien utile d'utilité en fin
de compte est très fort et que les
français sont encore très proche de nous
ouais vous dites les fantassins de la
république vous karl olive faut parler
des mères oui et tout à l'heure vous
disiez mon cher thomas eut que les mères
étaient découragés moi c'est exactement
l'inversé mais je n'y a pas de la
politique j'étais dans une autre vie que
me que vous connaissez qu'on partage oui
ou non 7e à ma place ou à notre place je
me permettrai pas mais je ne viens pas
de la politique en revanche je suis né à
poissy j'ai grandi à poissy élus en 2014
au premier tour à 62% et réélu à 75 % en
2020 avec des très bons résultats comme
franck peut les avoir du côté de la
boule pourquoi en fait on fait pas de la
politique nous sommes oui des fantassins
la république nous sommes des chefs de
chantier nous sommes en prise directe
avec la réalité du quotidien le matin
quand on se lève on se demande pas si on
va faire une politique de gauche ou de
droite on va faire une politique est
adaptée à celle de nos administrés est
pourquoi l adapter parce que nous les
connaissons et pourquoi nous les
connaissons parce que nous faisons du
terrain et quand vous faites du terrain
alors on est beaucoup plus pragmatique
le politique alors ce sera le thème de
notre second débat tout à l'heure donc
jeu mais je voulais quand même vous
entendre sur sur votre ressenti de 2,2
maire jean vient aux relations entre le
printemps république et et les maires de
france
c'est le premier adjectif ou le premier
mot qui vous vient à l'esprit pascal
perrineau pour les pour les caractériser
ses relations
difficiles difficile par rapport même à
d'autres présidents qu'ils soient de
gauche ou de droite qui l'ont précédé
difficile pour différentes raisons
d'abord emmanuel macron indépendamment
du fondateur le général de gaulle est le
premier président qui n'avait aucune
expérience d'élu local aucune d'élu
local ou d'ailleurs d'élus nationale et
donc cette culture pour lui est une
culture assez lointaine d'autre part
c'est un homme ce qui est assez fréquent
en france à gauche ou à droite c'est un
homme qui vient de la haute fonction
publique il a fait l'ena il a fait les
grands corps et il est l'expression de
cette culture de la haute fonction
publique qui regardent souvent d'un peu
de haut le terrain local comme étant le
terrain des intérêts particuliers
des affaires périphériques et qui
considère que l'intérêt général ça doit
venir du centre et ça doit aller vers le
bas donc pour toutes ces raisons qui
sont des réseaux voyez presque culturel
plus que politique la relation entre le
président et les élus locaux ont été
compliquées et au départ même cette aide
mauvaise relation il faut se rendre
compte que en 2018 en 2019 ce sont de
mauvaises relations parce que le
président ne comprend pas les élus
locaux il ya un malentendu et vous savez
comme disait le psychanalyste lacan
quand il ya un malentendu c'est qu' un
malentendant et malentendants était
plutôt à l'elysée que du côté que du
côté des élus locaux et puis les choses
se sont améliorées mais sous le concours
des circonstances et on n'en est pas là
évidemment cuillé la crise des gilets
jaunes on va rentrer dans le détail la
nôtre raison aussi fondamental c'est que
il était certes pas élu mais il ne
disposait d'aucun réseau d'élus son
parti n'existait pas c'est à dire qu'il
est arrivé et c'est lui-même qui utilise
cette expression faisant le casse du
siècle et il n'avait aucun parti pour le
soutenir donc aucun ancrage territorial
donc ils connaissaient d'autant moins
les mères puisque aucune aucun membre de
sa famille n'était présent dans les
territoires et c'était aussi des relais
pour sa politique qui pouvait lui manque
et karl olive pascal perrineau vient de
dire que grosso modo le prénom
république était mal entendants dans sa
relation avec les maires esquissé
trouver un sonotone depuis quelques
quelques mois ah ben si pascal perrineau
nous dit qu'on était plutôt avec berne
bernardo que que zorro entre 2017 et
2019 je crois qu'il a raison je pense
que entre 2017 et 2019 le président de
la république mais je vais aussi envie
de dire et c'est pas du tout un reproche
aussi ses députés qu'il n'avait pas de
codes politiques dont certains
découvraient découvrez la fonction
devait nous considéré plutôt comme des
chaînes de déraillements que des
courroies de transmission et puis un
jour j'ai eu un échange avec lui je me
souviens c'était un ordre décembre 2018
il m'a dit comment ça se passe sur le
terrain je suis absolument désastreux
parce que toutes les décisions que vous
prenez sur des décisions verticale vous
décidez on exécute on est pris pour des
jambons qu'est ce qu'on fait j'écoutais
je vais venir vous voir si vous en êtes
d'accord avec une délégation de
génération terrain 15 mai ronde et début
décembre au moment d gilet jaune je suis
président ça va pas vous plaire mais ça
vous rendre service et je me souviens
lui avoir dit au cours de l'entretien
qu'on a eu deux trois heures avec la
délégation de quinze maires toutes
obédiences politiques à les sentir le
cul des vaches ça c'est une expression
bretonne à les sentir le coup des vaches
descendait dans l'arène venez voir
comment ça se passe
on n'a pas été les seuls mais il ya eu
ce grand débat il ya eu ce tour de
france moi je suis content de voir le
reportage que vous passez ce micro
trottoir où cette personne dit on a eu
le sentiment enfin d'exister et oui nous
sommes devenus des fantassins la
république et des auxiliaires quelque
part de l'état des facilitateurs ça
c'était pendant le grand débat mais on y
reviendra sur le bilan du grand débat
puisque vous étiez en plein dedans
pascal perrineau vous pouvez nous nous
raconter comment ça s'est passé comment
vous vous l'avez vécu d'une certaine
façon franck louvrier est ce que vous
acceptez est-ce que vous intégrer l'idée
qu'il ya eu deux temps dans le dans le
quinquennat du président macron et que
finalement ça va mieux ou que ça c'est
pas franchement améliorée dans ses
relations avec les maires d'abord il ya
eu beaucoup de rendez vous manqué entre
le président de la république et je
dirais les maires bon il ya une chose
qu'il faut donc il faut faire attention
et c'était la suite du reportage c'est
que le rendez-vous du congrès des maires
est toujours un rendez vous très délicat
pour les présidents de la république
quel qu'il soit il ya deux rendez-vous
dans l'agenda du président la république
dans l'année qui sont très délicats
c'est le salon de l'agriculture ils
couraient des merveilles parce que bien
sûr c'est une relation directe avec des
gens qui ont généralement du tempérament
alors à la différence près c'est que les
maires sont aussi là pour
donner leurs parrainages et donc le
fêtait ses cons on a le prion la burqa
besoins des mères ont existé et pour
même se positionner sur la ligne de
départ donc il ya un rapport qui est
assez particulier dans notre république
entre les maires et le prise en mains
publiques alors l'actuel c'est vrai que
beaucoup de rendez vous manqués il ya eu
des rendez vous manqués parce que en fin
de compte il fait pas partie des nôtres
ils ont le sentiment les maires en
particulier qu'en fin de compte il n'a
jamais été élu comme vous le rappeliez
tout à l'heure et encore moins mer et
donc de ce fait là il ya bien sûr un
rapport qui est un peu je dirais
distancié à son endroit et qui fait que
lorsque il prend des décisions comme sur
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
qui bien évidemment est créé
amoindri l'autonomie de nos
collectivités quand il prend des
décisions sur certains sujets la loi sru
qui ne font que créer de
l'incompréhension dans j'irai le
quotidien des maires tout ça ne fait
qu'amplifier je dirais les difficultés
qui peut avoir avec l'ensemble des
maires mais si le cera un lieu depuis on
va dire l'après grand débat quand la
cicatrice est là elle n'a pas été bon en
tout cas la plaine n'a pas été notamment
je dirais soigner parce qu'on le voit
bien il n'y a pas eu de signaux très
forts alors vous citiez à juste titre la
tournée de france oui mais c'était on
disait c'est un monde réconciliation ça
plutôt été un moment d'espoir qu'un
monde réconciliation et d'espoir un
petit peu déçue après parce qu'ils n'ont
pas toujours obtenu ce qu'il souhaitait
justement pascal perrineau vous vous
l'avez suivi de près ce grand débat vous
étiez l'un des garants voilà le terme
que je cherchais tout à l'heure et qui
me revenaient pas je les retrouvais sur
mes notes ça voulait dire quoi et puis
quel bilan vous en tirer si vous voulez
en effet en plein mouvement des gilet
jaune le pouvoir tremble faut se
rappeler ça le pouvoir national tremble
sur ses fondements le président de la
république n'a plus de cap et le
président de la république va accoucher
de cette idée de mettre la france en
débat comme la france avaient été mises
en débat au moment de la révolution
française et de la rédaction des cahiers
généraux voilà parce que au fond voilà
dans le nouveau monde de macron il n'y a
plus de corps intermédiaires donc
comment fait-on quand il n'y a pas de
corps intermédiaires et bien on se
tourne vers la population vers ceux qui
la représentent le moins mal à savoir
les maires et on leur dit bah voilà
mettez-vous en débat le grand débat
national ça a été cela bien au delà de
l'opération de communication qui est l
opération d manueel mâcon qui a
rencontré en elle-même dans toutes les
régions des des maires de france dire
que l'important c'était ce qu'on ne
montraient pas forcément à la télévision
sur les chaînes d'info bien sûr parce
qu'il ya eu 2 millions de français ils
sont rentrés dans ce grand débat
national grâce au maire d'ailleurs parce
que très souvent c'est lé maire qui
prêtaient une salle municipale pour que
des citoyens et des citoyennes puissent
se réunir il y avait d'ailleurs assez
souvent moi j'ai fait des centaines de
débats du fait de ma fonction
il y avait assez souvent des gilets
jaunes qui discutait avec des citoyens
tout cela dans un calme relatif ce qui
n'était pas évident dans une france qui
à l'époque était extrêmement échauffés
et ç'a permis de faire redescendre la
température sociale et la température
politique et énormément de choses se
sont dites dans ce grand débat le gros
problème est la grande limite c'est une
fois de plus un état central qui reste
sourd à ce qui s'est dit parce que au
fond j'ai essentiellement d'ailleurs
dans mon bureau des piles entières de
résumés de ces grands débats qui s'en
est véritablement servi quels sont les
administrations d'état quel est le
gouvernement quels sont les ministères
qui se sont emparés de cette matière
première phénoménal presque en fait il
faut rappeler qu'il y avait des cahiers
de doléances qui étaient à la
disposition du public donc il y avait
quelque chose de très concret c'est
l'avenir que si on avait une
contestation à émettre une suggestion à
faire pour même au niveau de la commune
et pourquoi pas au niveau du pays on
pouvait la coucher sur ce cahier de
doléances mais c'est vrai j'ai envie de
vous poser la question vous aviez
répondu avant que finalement
l'application concrète de ces cahiers de
doléances n'a pas été vérifiée à bhl
comme la convention citoyenne sur le
climat c'est toujours pareil d'ailleurs
qu'il donne la parole mais ils n'en
tirent pas en tout cas de d'actions
concrètes on va poser la question à karl
olive parce qu'alors car le livre j'ai
en préparant les missions j'ai vu que
quand vous avez été promu chevalier de
la légion d'honneur le prennent en
république vous
vous décor est fait référence à cette
période en dix ans en vous remerciant
pour vos conseils à l'époque des des
gilet jaune alors est ce que finalement
avec le recul même si aujourd'hui vous
soutenez le prennent en république vous
dites que ça a débouché sur pas grand
chose ou que finalement on a levé un
espoir pour créer de la déception moi je
vois bien je suis venu je suis mené 3
sur le plateau là je vais absolument pas
être dans le sens de ce que j'ai entendu
on a vu dans les contributions vous avez
raison chère madame notamment dans des
deux lances je me souviens de plusieurs
administrés qui disait tant qu'on aura
un intérêt à rester chez soi plutôt que
d'aller travailler il y aura toujours de
l'injustice et de la justice sociale
dans notre pays quel est le discours du
président c'est exactement celui qu'on a
entendues entre la réciprocité
des droits et des devoirs deuxième
exemple des initiatives ou auparavant je
pense au plan banlieues mais pas
seulement on ouvre le robinet franck
louvrier c'est ça on ouvrait le oublier
le robinet de l'état et toutes les
communes qui piquent mans qui avait des
quartiers entiers de la ville
bénéficiait de subventions aujourd'hui
sa part du terrain est née coeur de
ville comme en est claire deville coeur
de ville n'est à l'issue du grand débat
à l'issue de ces doléances et enfin on a
quelque chose de concret qui fonctionne
je ne dis pas que tout est parti est-ce
que coeur de ville ça dit quelque chose
fins et excusez moi je sais que le
président va assister justement sur
cette cette politique coeur de ville
alors je vous donne un exemple la
communication elle est quand même faible
alors là on parle de 2,2 faire savoir
moi je suis quand même content qu'on
partage le savoir-faire sur le sur le
plateau vous avez un city stade à mettre
en place au coeur de ville peut y
participer vous avez la possibilité
d'acheter des commerces dans la
collectivité dans les artères
principales pour en faire devenir des
personnes dynamiques coeur de ville peut
y participer je fais actuellement une
voix douce qui longe la seine à poissy
coeur de ville finance à 70% et donc
c'est fléché projet par projet en est
bien la corse et ça c'est un art du
terrain et ça c'est très intéressant
parce que passer alpes et raynaud le
disais tout à l'heure on est passé de la
verticalité à cette organisation râteau
à une structure pyramidale c'est vrai
qu'il n'avait pas les codes les députés
n'avaient pas non plus moi j'aurais bien
aimé je vous josiane est typiquement que
la mf puisque c'est d'actualité soit
aussi un partenaire ma partenaire loyal
à ce moment là j'ai eu deux trois coups
de téléphone de personnes de la mf qui
m'ont dit les masques que ces pannes ou
les faire il est hors de question qu'on
fasse les masques les écoles il est hors
de question qu'elle ouvre on a besoin
d'eux mais dès l'es2 qui délai de quoi
est-ce qu'on doit tout attendre de
l'état est-ce qu'il a fallu que je
demande pour savoir où j'allais lé côté
sanitaire pour être quasiment la
première collectivité de france à ouvrir
ce centre scolaire pour les enfants de
personnel soignant et des forces de
police ça a très bien fonctionné le
président est venu je lui dis président
est là on va parler technostructure
président s'il avait fallu que nous
respections votre protocole sanitaire à
la con il n'y a pas une école de france
qui aurait ouvert et me dit tu as raison
et c'est là où on a effectivement besoin
de dire quand les choses vont bien quand
les choses vont mal mais moi je ne peux
pas dire que en deuxième mi temps on
n'est pas un président qui se
retroussent les manches qu'ils aillent
voir les maires d'ailleurs on le voit
dans ces visites encore aujourd'hui avec
beaucoup de visioconférence et je vais
vous dire moi j'en suis ravi parce que
c'est ce que nous attendons bon alors on
va voir ce que ce qu'attendent justement
les maires du présent et publics qui y
sera je vous le rappelle présents ici
jeudi marion delpech voilà et est allé
rencontrer des élus dans les couloirs du
congrès ici même qu'attendent-ils du
discours présidentiel jeudi il va
pouvoir nous amadouer mais pour ça il
est vraiment très très fort j'espère
qu'il a compris que nous les maires ton
soit de n'importe quel bord politique
mais on est là pour la république on est
là pour les français on est là pour la
démocratie au niveau des petites
communes ça a été cette relation a été
mal vécue il nous a fait un point très
difficile à digérer pour les communes
c'est la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation il n'y avait pas d'urgence
à faire porter cette mesure et ça nous a
mis un peu en difficulté sachant sachant
que ça a été ça a été recouvert par
l'état au niveau du faux sans doute un
un chef de bornes chef de troupe qui
nous donne un chemin sur lequel on va
peut-être un petit peu s'éparpiller les
uns les autres mais en tout cas qu'on
est une une direction commune et qu'on
arrive à sauver nos populations de cette
crise-là l'éthicien vous avez quelques
informations sur la teneur du discours
attendu jeudi oui enfin très petit mais
quand même c'est à dire que j'ai le
coeur le coeur de l'intervention du
président qui sera autour du lien le
lien qu'il a créée entre l'elysée et les
mairies et les maires et les territoires
et les populations
le lien de confiance le lien de solidité
pendant la crise sanitaire c'est à dire
qu'il mettra en avant cette solidité du
lien qui a permis à tous de tenir et de
finalement de s'en sortir là je vous
donne uniquement les éléments de langage
on est bien d'accord c'est à dire que ce
sera vraiment l'esprit du discours et
puis bien sûr il y aura ce lien entre
lui et les territoires rappelez vous il
avait donné une grande interview dans un
journal qui s'appelle zadig où il
parlait justement damien commune d'où il
vient parce qu'on a oublié qu emmanuel
macron était un provincial il parlait
aussi de marseille qu'il va le voir
souvent et puis il a compris qu'il
fallait flatter d'une certaine manière
alors je ne sais pas si le fait avec
vous messieurs les maires c'est à dire
que par exemple à la rochelle il va y
avoir un conseil des ministres
de la mer il va y avoir un ante un
conseil des ministres européens de
l'intérieur
donc voyez il voit là ils valorisent
certaines villes de france pour ensuite
donner ce sentiment je ne sais pas si
c'est une réalité d'une pyramide ou en
tout cas d'un jupiter qui serait un peu
redescendue sur terre est un peu
redescendue de deux du haut de la
pyramide du louvre qui était le symbole
de sa première soirée deux présidents
évidemment c'est à ça que vous faites
référence franck louvrier vous en avez
préparé quelques-uns des discours
présidentiel et notamment à l'occasion
d'un congrès des maires vous disiez vous
même que ça pouvait être difficile là on
est sur des éléments de langage le lien
quels mots quels mots justes pourrait
trouver le présent d'abord à quelques
mois des élections présidentielles la
crédibilité du discours du président de
la république sera très faible parce
qu'on sait très bien il donc période
électorale il va avoir besoin des maires
pour se représenter si je le souhaite et
donc de ce fait là plus vous approchez
l'élection plus votre crédibilité et les
faibles et donc le message sera très peu
entendu vous n'êtes pas sûr d'être réélu
quoi c'est comme un entraîneur qui qui
aidé à la fois un fou utilisé 10 et des
chocs et patiente le quota est enterré
les bulles résultats et le fait que le
discours est plus opportuniste
maintenant qu'il leur ait été il ya cinq
ans où c'est vrai que l'âme l'émirat
aurait été plus réceptifs et en et qui
savait qu'il avait le temps pour faire
quelque chose ce que souhaitent les
mères c'est pas des visioconférences ce
que souhaitent les mères c'est pas des
conseils des ministres dans des villes
où la délinquance explose comme à nantes
ce que souhaitent les mères c'est plus
de liberté plus de liberté dans leurs
actions locales et plus de
décentralisation pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui les élus et les maires
sont devenus des gens matures mur ils
sont capables de gérer leurs communes
ils ont les moyens humains ils ont des
moyens administratifs ils veulent plus
de moyens juridiques et parfois plus ou
moins bien merci c'est ça et c'est ça
l'enjeu est si vraiment il ya vu quelque
chose à faire dans ces cinq ans c'était
faire plus de décentralisation plus de
décentralisation ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire tout simplement c'est donner
plus d'autonomie aux communes et on a
fait exactement l'inversé on leur a
retiré le tonneau me financière avec la
taxe d'habitation on les emmerde pour
parler vulgairement
sur l'ensemble des constructions qui
peuvent faire notamment en matière de
logement où il ya une ministre du
logement qu'ils aillent d'eux des mers
parce qu'elle a un discours qui est
totalement aux antipodes de ce qu'on
veut entendre et de ce qu'on souhaite
quand vous voyez que le message qui a
été dire c'était d'augmenter de 20 à 25%
les logements sociaux avec la loi sru
dit inabordable pour une bonne partie
des communes quand on voit sur
l'artifice enfin bref on a plein de
sujets sur lesquels on n'a pas reçu un
message cinq sur cinq et six sur ces
sujets concrets que on veut des réponses
alors maintenant vous allez me dire bah
c'est normal il arrive c'est le diable
c'est son dernier congrès des maires
donc le dernier congrès des maires du
président de la république honnêtement
il va y avoir beaucoup d'humilité
karl olive est ce que vous avez quelques
quelques infos sur ce sur ce discours
présidentiel attendue jeudi mais je
crois que le président partage également
ce que dit franck louvrier c'est à dire
qu'il faut évidemment beaucoup plus de
simplification il l'a dit à de
nombreuses reprises
quand je lui propose par exemple de
rouvrir les stades de football les
gymnases et les par exemple les city
stade en lui expliquant qu'un terrain de
football c'est 6000 mètres carrés je le
fais vite 4,4 mètres carrés de
distanciation mais 1500 personnes dieu
n'a que vingt qui s'entraîne donc
jusqu'à ce qu'on nous emmerde avec ça va
vous faire un petit convention pour
gérer l'entrée et la sortie du stade
l'entrée et la sortie des vestiaires je
lui ai même proposé l'entrée et la
sortie des douches il m'a dit c'est une
très bonne idée je vous envoie quelqu'un
d'un ministère concerné le lendemain on
m'a communiqué pendant deux heures
pourquoi c'était pas possible je dis au
président on nous prend pour des jambons
président donc demain je vais ouvrir
envoyé le préfet puis il va mettre des
amendes s'il le faut on a ouvert donc on
a on a bousculé un petit peu voilà
l'ordre l'ordre énoncés et tout a été
ouvert par la suite donc la
simplification évidemment je pense qu'il
en est parfaitement conscient je pense
qu'il serait aussi de bon ton
typiquement il ya un sujet on voit bien
sur la facturation de ce qui s'est passé
pendant le coït de l'ensemble avec
l'ensemble des collègues maires de
france ne faut-il pas confier sa
s'adosser sur une structure existante
qui pourrait le comité des finances
locales par exemple pour avoir une
lecture partagée avec le président ça
peut être une piste est ce qu'ils
peuvent faut pas avoir une plateforme
commune d'interlocuteurs qui nous
permette systématiquement sur des sujets
prioritaires d'être d'être concerné je
dis pas d'être finalement dans la boucle
pour décider mais au moins d'être d'être
concernés et je pense que c'est des
choses qui peuvent apparaître et
évidemment va pas s'en plaindre après
franck pardon mais c'est pas ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui la centralisation ça fait
20 ans qu'on en entend parler donc si
c'est pour donner l'arrivée du tiercé
après après la course ça c'est très
facile et je sais que on partage la même
chose sur le travail très concrets que
vous menez à la baule je pense que
encore une fois nous sommes à même si on
nous fait confiance de bousculer encore
un peu plus ses habitudes de ce pays et
surtout de faire en sorte non pas de
faire gagner la gauche et la droite ça
c'est pipi de chat mais de faire gagner
la france et c'est ce qui nous rassemble
là la question des finances pascal
perrineau c'est intéressant parce que le
mandat de vous lire répondre oui parce
que sur les finances moi je vais vous
dire je vous donner un scoop je suis
persuadé que demain le président de la
république il va annoncer qui va nous
payer nos centres de vaccination mais je
veux dire heureusement moi ça m'a coûté
450 mille euros j'attends toujours le
remboursement de la facture mais vous
verrez ces annonces et si les annonces
en ce sens beaucoup de monde a envie de
vous demander à l'état de tout
rembourser de tous pays en fait il ya
quelque chose dans votre relation à
l'état qui est nommé no men origins nous
permettent pas d'avoir une politique
sanitaire je rappelle que la santé n'est
pas de compétence municipale et donc
quand nous on s'engage pas ce qu'il faut
répondre à une urgence sur le terrain
qui était de faire des centres de
vaccination ces centres de vaccination
on les fait mais on sait très bien que
on les fait au delà nos compétences et
on les fait parce qu'on n'en ait motivé
parce qu'on est conscient que nos
concitoyens ont besoin mais derrière
l'état doit quand même on est nous
soutenir financièrement sachant que ces
ne même pas dans le domaine de
compétence donc on peut imaginer que les
dépenses qu'ovide serait prise en charge
par l'état et là je reviens à ma
question ça serait la boucle serait
bouclée serre que son mandat aurait
commencé par on vous prend des sous en
retirant la taxe d'habitation puis on
vous ordonne à la fin du mandat à la
faveur de la crise sanitaire oui mais
tout ça si vous voulez sanaa ça n'est
pas à la hauteur du défi des territoires
vous savez tout 22 puis dès maintenant
plusieurs années on parle du défi des
territoires avec questions que posent
les territoires et la réponse politique
et administrative est toujours la même
plus de centralisation moins de
décentralisation je crois au fond qui a
eu une grande occasion manquée du
quinquennat d' emmanuel macron qui avait
dit voilà jean représente tout même le
nouveau monde le vieux monde c'était
quoi eh bien c'était une gauche et une
droite qui avait recentraliser qui avait
recentré alizés quand vous regardez sous
sarkozy comme ceux hollande il y à un
phénomène de recentralisation donc le
nouveau monde ça aurait été une un acte
3 audacieux de la décentralisation on en
a pas vu l'ombre et je crois que c'est
une des grandes occasions manquées du
cac du quinquennat d' emmanuel macron
karl olive ou dit souvent que même un
cran à dépoussiérer la politique qu'est
ce que vous répondez à cette critique
que typiquement si on en revient par
exemple à la mf moi j'estime et je vais
venir à ce que vous dites thomas hugues
que l'une des réponses pour moi de
l'affaiblissement ces dernières des
années de l'efs a été l'émergence
d'associations d'élus que le président
ne voyaient pas comme des syndicats
d'élus c'est pour ça qu'on a souvent été
contactés avec génération terrain avec
la france audacieuse avec les maires les
maires ruraux pour avoir un contact
direct qu'on n'a jamais vu jamais eu
auparavant mais évidemment qu'il faut de
plus de liberté évidemment moi je vais
vous dire le non cumul des mandats
député maire quelle connerie c'est
président demain pouvait nous dire deux
trois petites choses oui au statut de
l'élu qu'on arrête d'en parler depuis 20
ans et qu'on le fasse parce qu'on a des
collègues élus qui du jour au lendemain
se retrouve mis en examen responsabilité
pénale engagée alors que en face on n'a
pas le statut qu'ils qu'il convient et
ce n'est pas une question de c'est pas
une question de pépettes thomas il c'est
pas le sujet ça mais typiquement si on
pouvait voir ce ce type d' annonce
demain en tout cas des pistes de travail
pour qu'effectivement
approche les élus de terrain avec
l'exécutif alors ça on n'aurait pas
perdu de temps et ce serait pas de
l'opportunisme les annonces ici c'est
jeudi mais demain il reçoit les les
maires à l'elysée
ces deux annonces voilée il fera deux
annoncé deux choses d'abord ya un sujet
qu'il faut pas oublier c'est la sécurité
sur lequel là aussi depuis cinq ans on
peut pas dire qu'il ya eu plus de
responsabilité des maires alors qu'ils
en demandent mais ils ont demandé ils
demandent des moyens techniques
supplémentaires ils demandent des moyens
juridiques supplémentaires pas des joues
toujours des moyens financiers parce que
les communes aient les absorbent
beaucoup les dépenses en matière de
sécurité mais il ça c'est une demande
qui n'a pas encore été reçu cinq sur
cinq et puis sur l'histoire du cumul
bien évidemment le cumul il faut revenir
dessus et comme le dit à juste titre
karl olive c'est pas une histoire de
pépettes pour la simple et bonne raison
c'est qu'on a écrêté en france et donc
on peut pas avoir plus de 8500 brut
quand on vous avez une cumuler les
mandats donc l'affairé réglée mais il
faut revenir un peu en arrière ce qui
s'est passé avec les gilet jaune c'est
aussi la conséquence de la faiblesse du
parlementarisme après l'élection d'
emmanuel macron on s'est retrouvé avec
des parlementaires qui n'avaient pas
l'expérience et en fin de compte les
parlementaires c'est quoi c'est un à
noter un amortisseur social dans le pays
quand vous n'avez plus de gens qui font
des permanences quand vous avez des
parlementaires qui sont pas connues
quand vous avez des parlementaires qui
ne répondent pas aux questions du
quotidien et ben qu'est ce qui se passe
il ya plus que les maires et les maires
voulions recevoir dix personnes par jour
soit 20 parce que de ce fait là où vous
avez à l'embouteillage et les gilet
jaune en partie c'est aussi parce qu'il
n'y a pas eu cet amortisseur social et
politique était que sont normalement les
parlementaires dans une république comme
la nôtre alors je voudrais qu'on
revienne aussi en gilet jaune ya eu un
autre
événement assez marquant dans la
relation entre emmanuel macron et les
maires laetitia c'est ce ce hashtags
#tsunami
en est à l'automne 2010 8 c'est encore
une taxe qui déclenche le lincendie on
va dire oui oui mais c'est en fait c'est
gérald darmanin qui lance finalement la
polémique on l'a oublié parce que là
hashtag a pris tellement d'ampleur et la
polémique à gonfler très vite mais en
octobre 2018 il répond à une interview
du figaro et il donne la liste des 55
communes de plus de 10 mille habitants
qui contre l'avis du gouvernement avait
décidé d'augmenter la taxe d'habitation
annulant de fait la promesse du chef de
l'état du nouveau chef élu et à partir
de cette liste dévoilée par celui qui
était alors ministre des comptes publics
il y à des militants alors gilles
legendre à l'époque patron de l air eau
m avait dit que c'était des militants
marginaux sur twitter qui crée ce
hashtag balances ton mère évidemment
c'est dans le sillon de balances ton
port et donc ça s'apprend sur les
réseaux balances ton maire sous-entendu
celui qui a augmenté la taxe
d'habitation pour que tu n'es pas cette
promesse du président et c'est vrai que
la ml s'en étaient émus c'en était
saisie avait avait crié au dénigrement
irresponsable et ensuite tout le
gouvernement avait finalement fait
machine arrière et s'était désolidarisé
de cette cette initiative pascal
perrineau l'un pour oublier cet épisode
mais il a joué un rôle important bien
sûr dans l'histoire des relations entre
mâles macro les moeurs bien sûr parce
que il marque quelque chose qui reste un
dans l'image du président qui pourtant
dans la dernière période s'est améliorée
l'item sur lequel les français sont le
plus négatif vis-à-vis des manuels
macron c'est est proche des
préoccupations des gens comme nous hélas
les maires devraient et lui apprendre
quelque chose c'est qu'est-ce qui fait
la popularité des mères c'est qu'ils
sont proches des préoccupations des gens
comme vous et emmanuel macron semble
appartenir pour les français en termes
de perception a véritablement à une
autre planète et cet élément parmi
d'autres bien sûr où il marqué ou du
moins certains de ses soutiens
extrémistes on n'est pas responsable
heureusement de tous ses soutiens avait
créé cette hashtag balances ton maire aa
marqué le relatif mépris qu'il y a dans
une certaine culture de certains de nos
dirigeants vis-à-vis des élus locaux et
ça ne date pas d'aujourd'hui sa date
d'hier mais karl olive et puis après on
va avancer on va parler notamment de
l'élection de du président de
l'association des maires de france qui
se joue en ce moment il nous dit ça
change et sert que ce ce mépris
volontaire ou involontaire qui
s'affichait en dans les deux premières
années du mandat aujourd'hui alors yahia
vous vous arrêtez pas de me dire je le
conseille je lui dis fais ci fais ça
mais mais j'imagine quatre autres élus
qui en conseil ce serait bien
prétentieux non mais quand pascal
perrineau dit il habite sur une autre
planète que monsieur laignel dit c'est
le mensonge permanent tout ce qui est
excessif est pour moi un signifiant il
ya deux emmanuel macron il ya le mac le
mac rond de 2017 avec ses députés qui
découvre les codes qui découvrent la
fonction une parfois leur métier et puis
est ce qui se passe depuis et je dirais
actuellement et ça je pense que c'est
aussi important de le souligner je pense
qu on partage tous le fait ici que
certes la france ne va pas bien mais
elle va quand même mieux je rappelle
simplement que pendant l'épidémie l'aide
de l'état sur le plan de relance on
était les premiers de la classe européen
je rappelle que notamment côté sanitaire
on était sur le podium de la protection
sociale en france et je rejoins ce que
disait madame moi je pense qu'il faut
pas tout attendre de l'état quand il
s'est agi de d'avoir les masques moi
j'ai pas été demandée à l'état s'il
fallait acheter des masques ou je sois
remboursez remboursez par les masques
j'ai pris sur mon propre budget de
fonctionnement de la ville de poissy
l'acquisition de deux cent mille masques
pas fait en chine en france pour sauver
l'emploi et ça s'est très très bien
passé et la population les administrés
encore une fois je tout dépassant très
évidemment on l'a tous fait on sait tous
débrouiller système des premières
langues mais encore une fois je pense
que c'est bien de se demander ce que
l'état peut faire pour nous c'est bien
aussi de nous dire qu'est ce que je fais
pour mes administrés pour leur faciliter
leur quotidien parce que c'est notre
boussole alors vous le savez françois
baroin a choisi de ne pas se représenter
à la présidence de l'association des
maires de france il ya donc deux
candidats philippe laurent quelmer udi
de sault et david lisnard que le maire
ait l'air de cannes ils étaient tous les
deux ce matin sur public sénat ils se
sont succédé au micro dorian goscinny
dans bonjour chez vous on les écoute en
ce que la nfl doit être indépendante et
elle doit être un partenaire loyal de
l'état et pour être loyal il faut être
libre et donc pour être libre par
définition il faut pas être vassaliser
ou que la ml soit une antichambre du
pouvoir faut pas que l'élection de la mf
soit prise en otage par exemple par
l'élection présidentielle de l'année
prochaine
oui je pense oui est-ce que c'est trop
partisan parce qu'il ya la mise en avant
des partis politiques il ya la mise en
avant des écuries présidentielles
alors philippe laurent qui ne veut pas
politiser cette élection franck louvrier
est ce que
est ce que c'est le candidat malgré tout
deux emmanuel macron aurait coûté moi
moi je connais très très bien fini plan
je dirais même que c'est un ami en plus
si il a une résidence sur ma commune
donc
à nice mais la seule chose c'est que je
soutient david lisnard pour plusieurs
raisons c'est que d'abord c'est un homme
qui a de l'expérience
c'est un homme qui a vraiment une
expertise qui cherche à rassembler et
dans la liste qu'il présente c'est une
liste de rassemblement et ç'a toujours
été l'état d'esprit de la mf vous avez
des communistes vous avez des
socialistes vous avez des gens de ma
formation politique vous avez des gens
qui n'ont aucune appartenance politique
et c'est vraiment pas forcément le cas
dans sur la liste de
écoutez en tout cas ce qui a été fait il
y très est très clair en dans la
démarche de david lisnard ce qui est
moins clair de la part de fil blanc
sachant que ce qui est dommage dans
cette histoire c'est que j'aurais
préféré bien sûr qu'ils soient tous les
deux sur la même liste mais à partir du
moment où david fait une liste de
rassemblement la plus large possible
c'est vraiment l'état d'esprit que je
veux voir à la mf parce que en fin de
compte quand vous êtes maire comme le
disait à juste titre
karl olive vous n'êtes pas de gauche
vous n'êtes pas de droite vous pensez
pas comme ça le matin vous pouvez penser
ça le soir si vous allez à vos réunions
publiques politiques mais vous essayer
de gérer l'ensemble des problèmes de
votre population avec votre passion et
et
essayer d'emporter tout le monde eh bien
c'est exactement l'état des villes avec
l'état d'esprit david vous trouvez que
c'est une bonne idée d'avoir fait un
ticket avec un maire socialiste c'est ça
le nouveau monde aussi avec un
socialiste main dans la main ces je sens
que la bonne idée c'est d'avoir fait un
ticket avec tous ceux qui à un moment ou
un autre sont des gens engagés parce que
la politique c'est de l'engagement que
ce soit et enfin moyen d'imagés vous
êtes un spécial
problème
non mais vous avez des gosses non la
main droite gauche et aussi des gens qui
ont peu d'expérience et des gens qui en
ont beaucoup mais qui sont pas engagés
je pense que saturé tel état d'esprit de
françois baroin et c'est celui de david
lisnard et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je me retrouve dans la candidature de
david alors pascal perrineau qu'est-ce
qu'ils aient d'abord est ce que vous
êtes un spécialiste
évidemment des scrutins c'est ça va être
serré
vous avez des infos là dessus non aucune
à ras bord nous ne nous ordonner pas
alors qu'une info et qui se joue qu'est
ce qui se joue dans l'influencé
président de l'association des maires de
france peut avoir une influence
notamment sur un scrutin présidentiel
ah oui oui c'est une autorité qui pèse
tout à l'heure en effet franck louvrier
rappelait que tous les candidats ont
besoin de la signature de 500 ml locaux
ça compte et donc tout d'un coup des
mers qu'on pouvait considérer d'un peu
loin on les considère très attentivement
et on les choix donc ça s'éteint c'est
un élément fort et quand le président de
la mf parle il parle au nom de la
communauté de tous les maires et donc il
ya une certaine conception de la mf qui
en effet au delà des divisions
politiques qui sont normales qui sont le
coeur d'une vraie culture démocratique
en effet il faut savoir dépasser ses
sensibilités d'autre part il faut
rappeler tout de même qu'il y avait eu
un renouvellement des mers certes y
avait une abstention phénoménal mais il
ya un renouvellement des mers et que les
deux grands vainqueurs
c'est heller et le parti socialiste
c'est les ce sont les deux grands
vainqueurs des dernières élections
municipales
donc on les retrouve dans une coalition
avoué ou non dans cette élection interne
j'allais dire c'est un peu normal c'est
avoir entendu ce qui s'est dit sur le
terrain des élections municipales qui
est différent de ce que ce qui se dit
sur le terrain des élections nationales
et d'ailleurs c'est peut être un des
grands défis des mois qui s'ouvre il ya
de plus en plus ciblées pour
l'observateur que je suis une france
local avec des clivages qui sont des
clivages relativement traditionnelle qui
perdure qui sont là la gauche la droite
le centre et puis un un étage nationale
où il se passe autre chose est au fond
un des grandes des grandes questions de
la présidentielle sait quelle sera la
capacité des clivages qui s'exprime au
plan local à serez invités au plan
national ou non karl olive
vous avez annoncé pour qu'ils vous
alliez voter dans ce scrutin de la mf
oui oui je suis pas madame soleil donc
je n'ai pas attendu la fin de encore une
fois de la course pour annoncer
l'arrivée du tiercé je me suis engagé
derrière philippe laurent justin est
intéressant c'est que on partage autour
de de ces échanges nourris depuis
quarante-deux minutes tous les méfaits
de la verticalité pour laquelle nous
exécrons qu'est ce qui s'est passé à la
fin du mois d'août le président sortant
françois baroin que je respecte
profondément a décidé que ce serait
david lisnard et personne d'autre qui
lui succéderait je décide il a aidé vous
et comment vous exécutez en l'annonçant
là il ya ilahi vers une décision
démocratique alors
juste et d'ailleurs on se demande mais
pourquoi philippe philippe plan qui est
ici depuis une vingtaine d'années qui a
toujours été présent qu'à l'expérience
effectivement de terrain peu mal le
prendre ben oui on peut être un peu très
mal le prendre quand on est mis devant
le fait accompli même pas dans la boucle
je veux dire aussi que david lisnard que
je connais aussi très bien est amer de
terrain un très bon maire de cannes
le sectarisme qu'on entend depuis des
années et je le redis depuis tout à
l'heure monsieur laignel qui dit que
c'est le mensonge permanent c'est ça le
côté non partisan de la part du
président et publique ses salles côté
non partisan donc on va repartir sur les
mêmes bases avec l'addition d'étiquette
politique c'est exactement ce que les
maires de france ne souhaite pas donc
évidemment il ya une compétition qui est
très intéressante parce qu'en 2017 y
avait simplement deux mille votants
cette fois ci les 36000 maires de france
peuvent voter façon numérique et ça
c'est formidable et que le meilleur
gagne mais c'est bien de ces cancers
sont rarement mathématiques mais si on
écoute pascal perrineau effectivement
les républicains et les socialistes sont
sortis gagnants des dernières élections
municipales est donc mathématiquement et
devrait y avoir un vote majoritaire pour
le ticket lisnard et le maire socialiste
faut pas raisonner comme ça parce que
les mères john pas avec des étiquettes
politiques lorsqu'ils votent pour le
président des maires il est il raisonne
par rapport à celui qui pourra les
emporter à la fois dans les mesures qui
de qu'on devra prendre dans l'est dans
les années à venir et aussi parfois du
bras de fer qui peut arriver avec l'état
qu'ils soient de gauche ou qui sera
droite c'est pas le sujet donc c'est la
force plus que l'engagement politique
oui compte mais franck louvrier si c'est
david lisnard qui est choisi il va il va
s'engager dans la campagne
présidentielle et il sera critique
vis-à-vis de l'exécutif et il a le droit
d'avoir une survie il a le droit d'avoir
plusieurs vies comme nous tous et au
delà de ça on sait pas ce qu'on lui
demandera nous ce qu'on lui demandera
c'est de défendre les maires et défendre
leurs préoccupations au quotidien et
c'est là dessus qu'on conjure a bien
évidemment le prochain président merci
beaucoup merci à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce premier débat laetitia
vous restez